six days before the start of the World
Cup clashes Brazil would rather the
world did not see on the second day of a
metro strike in Sao Paulo Benny for the
first game
police fire tear gas and stun grenades
of protesters
strike added to congestion on the city's
notoriously busy roads it couldn't stop
fans heading for Brazil's last warm-up
game the tournament and its organizers
have not always been popular here
passion for the men who were the most
famous shirt in football is undimmed one
protest group even called off a planned
demonstration of the game out of respect
for the national team
though the police were taking no chances
there's huge excitement here among
supporters as the World Cup approaches
me and officials hope that once the
football starts the problems that dog
the build-up to this tournament will be
quickly forgotten but for FIFA this
world cup might be the least of their
worries FIFA's executive committee will
meet today it's the first time since new
corruption allegations surrounding the
award of the 2022 tournament to qatar
has been very embarrassing for this
human nature being what it is people
only believe what they read Dante that
they don't look at all of the many good
things Sepp Blatter says he's waiting
for the outcome of an independent
investigation but with the Sunday Times
promising further revelations FIFA's
reputation is again on the line for
Blatter and Brazil the real football car
comes soon in a poor kelso Sky News so
Paolo